pour dire les choses clairement ce texte
sur lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui est un texte de
police des étrangers dans la quête d'un
électorat perdu le gouvernement et la
droite ont choisi de se fondre dans la
rhétorique que seulle l'extrême droite
défendait jusqu'alors la France au
français je vous le dis comme je le
pense la violence de ce texte nous
heurte ce texte est une honte d'heure en
heure de recul en recul de marchandage
en marchandage la droite a entraîné une
majorité résidentielle complaisante dans
un ravin populiste sous l'œil gourmand
de l'extrême droite en toute logique en
toute
logique cette extrême droite votera ce
projet de loi ce projet de loi elle
aurait même pu l'écrire cette extrême
droite Rance haineuse qui se frotte les
mains en contemplant ce spectacle cette
marée brune qui fait sauter toutes les
digues les unes après les autres mes
chers
collègues mes chers collègues
je suis inquiet pour mon pays pour son
avenir que reste-t-il de nos valeurs de
nos idéaux de la France pays des droits
de l'homme par deux fois Emmanuel Macron
est arrivé au pouvoir car nous car nous
étions nombreux à espérer qu'il fasse
barrage à l'extrême droite aujourd'hui
le même Emmanuel Macron amène les idées
d'extrême droite au pouvoir je
m'adresse je m'adresse aux
parlementaires qui de bonne foi ont cru
en même temps du président de la
République ouvrez les yeux en 2027
allez-vous assumer d'avoir donné corps
aux pires excès de l'extrême droite
assumerez-vous d'avoir gravé la
préférence nationale dans le marbre de
la loi assumerez-vous d'avoir privé les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que leurs enfants de moyens de
subsistance pendant plusieurs années
assumerez-vous d'avoir mis à terre les
principes de la nationalité
assumerez-vous d'avoir imposé aux
étudiants des conditions inatteignables
pour rejoindre nos universités assume v
d'avoir réduit les travailleurs dans les
métiers enenstion à de simples variables
d'ajustement assumerez-vous de n'avoir
pas fermé la porte à la remise en cause
de l'aide médicale d'État les
dispositions que vous avez voté depuis
hier soir sont une insulte à nos
lumières comment d'ailleurs nos
collègues centristes comment nos
collègues centristes depuis la première
lecture au Sénat peuvent-ils accepter de
prêter la main à une telle dérive
extrémiste à rebour de leur propre
histoire non mes chers collègues un
étranger n'est pas appariss c'est un
danger pour notre civilisation notre
mode de vie notre activité économique
vous vous êtes laissé submerger par des
fantasmes d'un autre temps non seulement
vous renoncez à nos valeurs fondatrices
mais avec ce texte vous ajoutez du
désordre au désordre le droit des
étrangers sans pile des enfants non
accompagnés sont à la rue des situations
d'étrangers sont examiné de manière
partielle et partiale les ooctf sont
délivrés n'importe comment elles ne sont
pas appliquées mes chers collègues ce
1912 marque l'entrée de la droite et du
centre dans la majorité présidentielle
au risque de leur propre disparition ce
19 décembre sonne la rupture de la digue
défendue pendant de nombreuses années
par la droite française contre l'extrême
droite ce 19 décembre le Front
républicain a fait long feu vous avez
inventé la cohabitation d'opportunités
la coalition sans contrat la collision
la collision du renoncement mais
rappelez-vous les Français préféreront
toujours l'original à la copie vous êtes
vainqueur peut-être ce soir mais
êtes-vous vraiment les biciire de cette
victoire vous avez choisi de tourner le
dos à ce beau concept écrit par l'un des
vôtres mieux vaut perdre une élection
que perdre son âme je termine
rassurez-vous un vent mauvais souffle
sur notre territoire pour notre part en
gardant la nu nous voterons contre ce
projet de loi
[Applaudissements]
immigration